hey this is dr. John dallona with Ramsey
Network and it's awesome to see you
today this week we're gonna be talking
about what happened here what happened
here
and what happened in our communities and
our families and we're going to talk
about a subject that's a big deal to me
as a crisis responder as a trauma worker
and it's just a dad and a husband and so
for the next couple of days we will be
talking about what happened what can we
do about it and then how can we do it
well right and how can we all be hold
together moving forward all right so
let's roll back about two months here we
go the email started coming in hey we're
gonna extend Spring Break a week right
and then all of a sudden uh schools
cancel and then little leaks cancelled
and then basketball games quit playing
and the NBA stop playing games and a
musician buddy of mine had thousands of
dollars of gigs that just vanished
overnight not big groups now my church
isn't meeting we did Easter by ourselves
for the first time in my whole family's
anything right millions and millions of
people out of work and this domino just
started falling and it got big and it
got little right my son lost his tenth
birthday right all the friends we had
coming over gone my daughter celebrated
her Easter party she's four celebrated
her Easter party via zoom and it was
just a drunken chaotic mess there was no
drinking but it felt that way right and
then I had a couple of buddies who lost
parents like elderly parents they had to
have tiny funeral small get-togethers it
broke my heart when one of my friends
detailed with losing her dad and not
being able to hug her own mom at her
funeral because she was in a high-risk
category if you watch the Internet's we
saw folks cycle in and out of disbelief
in pure adrenaline and let's solve this
and Pinterest stuff blew up with here's
how to home-school here's how to do this
and as the country starting to wake up
and figure out what tomorrow's gonna
look like and we're gonna play half of a
baseball season with no people in the
stands and our summer vacation schedules
are all gonna be canceled right they're
gonna be modified or here-here we may be
able to go to church once a month or get
our hair cut somewhat
we figure out what's coming I want to
make sure that as the adrenaline fades
as the excitement of all this goes away
as we start to live into the reality
that millions and millions of people are
out of work and trying to claw their way
back into the workforce as we all wake
up I want to make sure that we don't
miss out on one key foundational element
and that is that we have to grieve what
we lost if we just brush over the missed
graduations we blow off the missed proms
we just say oh man I lost that job I
didn't like it anyway let's go get the
next one if we don't realize what
happened by canceling a chunk of the
school year
if we don't acknowledge these things
they're gonna eat us up from the inside
and so we often think of grief as what
you do when somebody dies something big
it's a big neon sign that flashes this
is grief you get three days off of work
and then you got to go back and you
should be over about it and I want to
suggest that grief is something that
happens with any loss any time we have
pain because all pain is is a signal
that we loved something that we were
excited about something that we're gonna
miss something
and that can be big and that can be
small so I want to give you three things
today that it's so important when it
comes to grieving number one you have to
give yourself permission to grieve this
is not the time to be tough this isn't
time to hit the gas and drive through it
it's not the time to say my stuff didn't
matter I just had to get gotta give
yourself space to stop and sit down and
say that sucked
he's got to get a piece of paper and
write down I lost this I lost this I was
dreaming about this I plans for that
number two you got to give other people
space to grieve as well it's real easy
to tell my daughter is just your program
that none of us no one likes to go to an
Easter program anyway right or you're
the worst thing on earth someone else's
graduation ceremony you're just sitting
there for hours just wishing someone
would spontaneously combust for
something to watch right you're just
sitting there
it's the worst but it meant something to
them and it meant something to their
family and to their granddad who didn't
get to go to college and worked 12 hour
a day seven days a week for his whole
life so that one day his grandkid could
go let's go these things mean something
to us collectively and we have to give
other people permission to grieve and
this is so important
every body grieves differently and that
brings me to number three we cannot
compare grief my grief isn't better than
yours and yours isn't less than mine and
so what some of us do when we're trying
to be tough
is we say man this hurts I haven't
missed a family Easter in 10 years but
they missed a graduation and yeah we
missed a graduation but they had
somebody get sick and go the hospital
here's the thing loss is loss and pain
is pain and hurt is hurt and grief is
universal don't compare grief if it
hurts it hurts if you've got pain
acknowledge it
if your friends are hurting acknowledge
it one of the things that breaks up
couples who go through significant loss
like the loss of a child or the loss of
a parent is it it hurts for both but
that people grieve differently and over
time they start to think shouldn't you
be over that by now and why aren't you
crying enough and it all comes back to
comparing grief in this season you got
to give yourself space to grieve you've
got to give those around you
collectively folks you don't even know
this country you've got to give others
space to grieve and you cannot compare
grief let people hurt feel it and then
go breed brave and forth for a bonus I
know I only said three but here's a
fourth bonus you cannot grieve alone
thank you for joining me today if you
want more information on grief wrestling
with the big picture of the small
pictures click at the link below I've
got an article videos wrote it's at Dave
Ramsey com don't forget to subscribe to
the channel I'm gonna keep this going
and going and I love hanging out with
you I don't have a lot of friends this
is good for me and follow me at John
Bologna and I will see you soon take
care